[Musique]
alors on veut des révélations on veut
des scoop on veut des doses comme on dit
sur le Squeezie et bien vous allez être
servi [ __ ] les amis à chaque fois j'ai
l'impression que j'ai pas d'autre
anecdotes à raconter et à chaque fois en
fait les jours passent les nuits passent
les douches passent parce que oui la
douche ta maman qui stimule ta
créativité et hop j'ai des souvenirs qui
remonte gros et à chaque fois c'est pas
des trucs qui me mettent en valeur du
tout c'est génial j'ai été un boulet
pendant des années je suis encore mais
je m'en rendrai compte que dans 8-9 ans
et je vous raconterai des trucs que j'ai
fait maintenant dans le 8 9 ans c'est
chiant cette phrase je gagne du temps
parce que je profite de cette dernière
seconde vous n'êtes pas au courant de
certaines choses et voilà allez je vous
raconte tout comment j'avais 11 ans
j'habitais dans la banlieue parisienne
du nom d'Antony un endroit très ghetto
c'est faux entièrement faux la plupart
des gens ont des maisons les gens vivent
très très bien tout allait bien pour moi
puisque je n'étais pas encore très
addict aux jeux vidéos je jouais de
manière raisonnable puis je sortais
m'amuser avec mes amis des fois j'allais
à la piscine
même si j'avais fait me noyer là je vous
avais raconté cette vidéo dans une autre
vidéo c'est pas grave le Lulu il
continue de pratiquer ces petites
longueurs à la piscine ça lui fait du
bien et ce sont un petit peu à quoi man
ce jour-là on était en juin grand soleil
dans le ciel je me dis ça y est c'est
mon jour aujourd'hui je vais nager plus
vite qu'un poisson j'arrive à la piscine
je peux ma petite place je vais me
changer là ces moments chiant tu mets le
bonnet de bain qui a la pire texture du
monde les mecs stylé ils avaient un
bonnet de bain en toile moi j'avais subi
en plastique qui te tire les vœux quand
tu le mets le pire bonnet frère je suis
sûr que ça là c'est à cause de ce
monnaie à l'époque il m'en a arraché les
cheveux mec bon bref je sors du
vestiaire je marche en direction de la
piscine je passe ce fameux bain pour
pied
ignoble dans lequel il y a toutes les
maladies du monde mec elle a tuberculose
là-dedans et comme la plupart des gens
au lieu de marcher dedans je marche sur
le rebord pour le contourner et en
arrivant j'ai une petite tradition
souvent mais vous avez à la piscine
municipale il y a souvent le le bassin
aux dimensions olympique pour faire tes
longueurs et tout quand tu es un beau
gosse et il y a le petit bassin tu sais
pour les gens un peu enfant ou les gens
qui ont un retard mental comme moi et ce
bassin là il a un avantage c'est que
l'eau est plus chaude que dans l'autre
bassin alors à chaque fois je vais pour
habitude de faire un petit tour dans ce
petit bassin avant d'aller dans le grand
mais dans le petit bassin il y avait
tous les mecs comme moi qui voulais pas
affronter la fraîcheur du grand bassin
et du coup il était tout le temps BL
indé de ce bassin mec et là j'arrive
miracle il y a personne les gens sont
autour du bassin mais ne sont pas dedans
je me dis [ __ ] j'ai le petit bassin
pour moi tout seul ça y est c'est le
plus beau jour de ma vie je me sens un
petit peu comme Bill Gates comme s'il
avait mon jacuzzi privé vous sentez la
douille arriver je tape le plus beau
sprint de ma vie en direction du bassin
je fais mon plus beau sans vers le petit
bassin j'atterris dans l'eau j'ai
l'impression d'être le roi du monde et
quand je monte à la surface les emmerde
commence il y a un mec dans l'eau en
face de moi qui me regarde un peu
bizarre alors je comprends pas je me dis
merde est-ce que mon saut était
tellement stylé que je l'ai fait
complexer je sais pas [ __ ] ah bah
j'avais de l'ego déjà à l'époque et là
je vois que dans sa main il a un
instrument bizarre que je saurais pas
identifié mais j'ai jamais vu un mec à
la piscine avec ça c'est une frite ni un
harpon ni un jet ski alors c'est quoi et
parallèlement à ce que j'observe
j'entends des rires tout autour de la
piscine je comprends pas mec est-ce que
j'ai perdu mon choix de bain dans le feu
de l'action et je réalise que ce qu'il a
dans la main c'est un aspirateur
aquatique et qu'il était en train
d'aspirer la merde qu'un enfant avait
fait 10 minutes avant que je plonge dans
l'eau c'est bon
vous vous doutez bien étant donné qu'il
était vraiment collé à moi le mec
j'avais vraiment sauté sur la merde
j'étais ravi je sors de l'eau j'ai très
très honte cette fois-ci en marchant
dans le bassin où il y a la tuberculose
au cas où nettoyer les les résidus s'il
y en a jamais de caca sur mes pieds je
retourne au vestiaire la meuf de
l'accueil voit que je retourne au
vestiaire et me dire ça c'est mal passé
ça va tout va bien mais c'est moi je
veux devenir invisible alors
actuellement vous comprenez ça je veux
plus personne ne me parle pendant deux
semaines je vais mourir je suis rentré
chez moi humilier ma dignité est restée
dans le bassin tout comme la merde de ce
jeune garçon si toi qui regarde cette
vidéo tu as souvenir d'avoir chié dans
le petit bassin de la piscine municipale
de Anthony bah va te faire [ __ ] ok je
règle mes comptes Man en disant après
c'est bon voilà la première révélation
est faite j'ai sauté dans un bassin
rempli de caca on peut passer à autre
chose c'est bon merci deuxième anecdote
ça s'est passé quand j'étais au lycée en
seconde j'étais dans un centre
commercial qui s'appelle Okabé qui se
situe au Kremlin-Bicêtre pareil pas très
loin d'ailleurs de d'Anthony c'est les
détails de merde mais il faut que je
gagne du temps sur la vidéo encore une
fois là vous n'êtes pas au courant de ce
qui va suivre donc ma dignité est encore
un peu présente j'avais des potes qui
devaient me rejoindre là-bas et je sais
pas pourquoi j'ai une grosse idée de gag
nul à chier mec vraiment une blague nul
vraiment genre le gars du cafard en
plastique à côté c'est énorme je vais un
supermarché qui avait dans le centre
commercial et je me dis [ __ ] avant que
mes potes arrivent je vais acheter une
teinture et je vais me la faire et comme
ça quand ils arriveront les cheveux
noirs et ils comprendront pas
trop drôle alors je me suis remarcher je
veux rayon teinture il y en a des
milliards des milliards mais je sais pas
qui avait autant de marques qui faisait
des teintures je prends une teinture et
je vois un petit sur le côté la boîte
qu'il a marqué attention tu vas acheter
une teinture et on te dit attention
bizarre tester la teinture avant de
l'appliquer sur votre cuir chevelu ah
pour voir si j'aime la couleur et que je
suis sûr de bien vouloir prendre
celle-ci et pas une autre ou mettez un
peu de produit sur une toute petite
partie de votre peau pour voir si elle
ne réagit pas mal pendant les 24
prochaines heures ah oui c'est vrai que
des gens sont allergiques aux teinture
mais pas moi
je ne dirige alors avec ma teinture
toute neuve dans les toilettes du centre
commercial on en est là on en est là le
mec va au bout de son gag il se dit pas
un moment peut-être que c'est une idée
de merde je mets ma tête sous l'eau en
plus le lavabo était petit donc j'avais
genre la tête coincé entre le robinet et
l'évier c'est un enfer j'applique la
teinture je rince je suis content je
sors des toilettes avec les cheveux
noirs mes potes étaient déjà arrivés le
gag marche très peu ils font vraiment ah
bah tu sais teint les cheveux en noir on
va manger mais merde la suite est bien
plus triste le soir je me couche et mon
crâne me gratte énormément je me gratte
je me gratte je me gratte puis je me dis
quand ça te gratte généralement faut pas
trop de gratter ça empire le truc tu
vois un peu comme un bouton de moustique
alors j'arrête de gratter je dors très
mal très très mal le matin je me lève je
me regarde dans le miroir et là mec je
fais une découverte exceptionnelle
c'était la taille de mon crâne il avait
triplé de volume mec ma tête c'était une
montgolfière mon pote je ressemblais en
alien de Mars Attack frère j'ai vu ma
mère ma mère a explosé de rire moi
j'étais en pleurs je me disais mais
c'est grave ça se trouve ma tête va
vraiment exploser quoi je suis pas allé
à l'hôpital je me suis dit bon bah ça va
passer c'est une petite allergie rien de
grave [ __ ] il y a pas quelqu'un autour
de moi qui m'a dit peut-être c'est le
médecin on sait jamais le surlendemain
je me réveille nouvelle surprise il y
avait l'équivalent de cette bouteilles
d'eau en liquide dans mon front c'est ce
qu'on appelle de l'œdème j'avais une
poche mec dans mon front dos vraiment
star matelas ou le truc je décide alors
d'aller aux urgences parce que là c'est
chaud quoi à Monsieur Michael il me dit
ah vous a fait une allergie à une
teinture vous je lui dis oui il me dit
bon je vais appuyer sur votre front pour
voir si l'ODEM est vraiment énorme parce
que si il est vraiment énorme il peut
peut-être se prolonger dans votre coup
et ça va appuyer sur vos voies
respiratoires et vous allez mourir
oui bah vas-y appuie moi sur le front
mec mets-moi des coups même dans le
front vas-y je veux pas mourir le mec
mais sa meilleure force dans son doigt
pour appuyer sur mon front son doigt
s'enfonce dans mon front on ne voit plus
son doigt et en sortant son doigt il me
dit bah c'est rien vous en faites pas
allez bonne nuit mais donne-moi un truc
peut-être pour que ça dégoûte pour que
je me sente mieux pour que j'arrête de
complexer pour short de ma dépression je
sais pas je rentre comme ça
tranquillement sur mon trottoir je
marche en direction de la maison je me
dis tout ça ne sera bientôt qu'un
mauvais souvenir au pire c'est pas grave
ça reste entre moi et ma mère mais
personne du lycée n'était au courant mon
honneur est sauf et sur le trottoir d'en
face un mec me regarde il me reconnaît
il explose de rire et continue son
chemin autant vous dire que je n'ai pas
passé un bon l'Institut
mon
crâne à partir de jour je n'ai plus
jamais osé me tendre les cheveux
sont très violets les amis maintenant
trêve de plaisanterie nous passons à la
dernière anecdote qui est celle où j'ai
le plus de regrets où j'ai merdé comme
jamais ma mère m'envoyait chaque année
en colonie et elle m'avait envoyé trois
ou quatre années de suite dans la même
colonie qui était une colonie de cheval
elle savait que j'adorais les animaux du
coup j'étais tout content je voyais des
chevaux j'ai caressé je fais du cheval
j'étais heureux ça dure entre une et
trois semaines une colonie vous savez
très bien que certains soirs waouh on
fait le mur bah oui on sort en cachette
de la chambre en faisant attention au
ronde des animateurs pour pas qu'il nous
prennent la main dans le sac et qu'on
soit puni ce soir là c'était le dernier
soir de la colonie et on avait décidé
avec mes potes d'aller dans le dortoir
des filles toc le problème c'est que
dans ce centre équestre le dortoir des
filles se trouvait à l'opposé du dortoir
des hommes on avait un pote qui était en
crush sur une fille mais ça je le savais
pas à l'époque et c'était le dernier
soir et il avait pas osé franchir le pas
et il était trop deg et nous en tant que
bon pote on lui a dit mec ce soir on va
atteindre le dortoir des films et tu vas
dormir avec Noémie noémie est dans la
meuf sur qui là-bas un crash bien
entendu vous l'avez compris alors on
sort de la chambre un modérateur passe
devant nous il ne nous voit pas on
traverse le couloir on finit par sortir
du bâtiment et là on se retrouve en
extérieur le problème c'est qu'à
l'extérieur se trouvait sur quasiment
tous les murs des spots automatiques qui
avaient une zone de détection très très
large si un spot s'allume ça veut dire
que quelqu'un est passé devant ça veut
dire que les animateurs vont venir vers
le spot et fouiner dans les environs et
se passer le mot en gros on est mort
c'est un spot de texte ok vous comprenez
ça alors on s'avance discrètement de
buisson en buisson il y a un spot on
peut pas passer devant parce que sinon
on passe devant le bureau de la
direction dans lequel il y avait des
animateurs qui devaient leur café leur
clope là enfin ils buvez pas des clopes
il est fumer mais bon vous m'avez
compris du coup on est obligé de faire
un détour et de passer par l'intérieur
de l'enclos des chevaux en pleine nuit
alors on passe dans cet enclos pour
esquiver le spot mon pote marche dans
une merde on se retient de rire parce
que vous savez c'est c'est horrible
cette situation où tu as envie d'exposer
de rire mais tu sais que tu exploses de
rire tu es mort mais du coup tu es
encore plus envie d'exploser de rire on
est dans le couloir qui mène au dortoir
des filles
Noémie on arrive on ouvre la porte du
dortoir on rentre l'une des filles dit
[ __ ] ça pue d'un coup quelqu'un a pété
non non c'est juste nous qui traversait
les enclos des chevaux et là Arnaud mon
ami va dans le lit de Noémie je sais pas
ce qui me prend je vais dans le lit de
Noélie avec lui
pourquoi mais moi j'étais innocent
j'avais 11 ans moi j'avais pas de penser
un peu pervers ou je sais pas quoi pour
moi les hommes et les femmes ne
faisaient pas l'amour ils pouvaient quoi
habiter en toute liberté sans jamais
avoir des attirances des uns pour les
autres le sexe ça n'existait pas là vous
vous dites mais au pire ça les a pas
empêché de discuter de s'embrasser sur
lui s'embrasser ah mais non attendez je
me glisse entre Arnaud et Noémie de
manière vraiment [ __ ] toutes les
chances d'Arnaud d'avoir un quelconque
contact physique avec Noémie avec Noémie
on parle on parle Arnaud des fois il
arrive à 5 continents la con mais on
parle avec nos mais on parle et Arnaud
me met des petits coups de coude un peu
comme ça de plus en plus fort au début
léger mais d'un coup hop là un petit
coup un peu hargneux comme ça je
comprends pas pourquoi il fait ça et je
lui dis mais Arnaud pourquoi tu mets des
coups de coude le pyramide possible du
coup Noémie elle comprend un Carnot il a
envie de se rapprocher d'elle et qui
c'est pour ça qu'il met des coups de
coude Noemie elle engueule Arnaud mais
Arnaud pourquoi tu mets des coups de
coude à Lucas tu es malade je finis par
sortir du lit il passe 3 minutes dans le
lit avant de se faire exclure du lit par
Noémie qui était trop fatigué parce
qu'on avait parlé pendant 1h30 et là
Arnaud me passe un savon je croyais
qu'on était pote ce que tu as fait c'est
abusé à cause de toi j'ai pas pu
l'embrasser et je la reverrai plus après
10 jours et
ça se trouve mec il serait marié
aujourd'hui si j'avais pas fait ça ça se
trouve c'était le début d'une grande
histoire Arnaud vraiment désolé d'avoir
[ __ ] ton flirt j'espère qu'aujourd'hui
tu penses plus à elle que c'est de
l'histoire ancienne est vraiment je
m'excuse j'aurais dû comprendre ce qui
se passait entre toi et elle sentir
cette petite électricité et vous laissez
les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu et que vous
ne m'en voulez pas je sais que à tous
les mecs qui ont vu la vidéo on le seum
contre moi on a pas envie que ça nous
arrive à nous ce que j'ai fait à Arnaud
j'étais jeune innocent et je me rendais
pas compte de ce que je faisais vraiment
mais je m'en veux si vous saviez comme
je m'en suis voulu qu'elle lui donne
après quand j'ai compris ce que j'avais
fait à cet homme n'hésitez pas à aimer
la vidéo si elle vous a plu j'espère que
vous aimerez quand même mes vidéos après
avoir appris que j'ai sauté dans une
piscine remplie de caca ou que j'ai une
tête montgolfière ou que j'ai empêché un
pote de pécho écoutez moi je vis plutôt
bien malgré toutes ces erreurs ça peut
être trop d'impact je me porte bien bon
voilà n'hésitez pas à me dire dans les
commentaires si vous avez gaffé avec un
pote qui avait un crush sur une meuf ça
peut être drôle c'est trop drôle ces
histoires là c'est horrible mais c'est
très drôle à la fois je vous fais plein
de bisous j'espère que ça vous a plu
j'ai encore d'autres anecdotes pour une
future vidéo anecdote décidément
j'arrête pas d'en avoir en ce moment
c'est incroyable et je vous dis à
bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
portez-vous bien au revoir
[Musique]